l' avantage des vidéos de ces vidéos on
est tranquille chez nous ainsi sur yonne
que notre alors que pas leur candidat
on est peut-être sous la pluie il y aura
plus assez de sherbrooke
je remarque que ces pratiques menacent
le potala regret gautschi ben voilà
[Musique]
est ce que vous êtes chaud
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est ce que vous savez ce que c'est l'art
oratoire ces derniers coûtent alors oui
c'est une des choses il faut savoir
écouter
exactement c'est l'art de parler face à
un public et pas avoir peur donc est ce
que vous pouvez me citer des orateurs
que vous aimez oui the rock tu connais
pas qu'est ce que c'est aso rock à
l'acteur tu veux dire le acteurs très
barak là d'accord
ronaldo le joueur de foot d'accord oui
oui main l'ema ça c'est plutôt des
joueurs de foot
il s'exprime sur le terrain avec les
pieds qui d'autre oui je nomme jean
lassalle qui ça jean lassalle d'accord
[Musique]
fais pas pour moi vous fait pour vous
pour vous défendre parce que le monde
il appartient aux gens qui savent parler
et qui savent argumenter l'argumentation
si je la tiens de six mois de vie de ma
mère ça allait toujours dans le monde en
tout cas l'argumentation je pense que
c'est beaucoup moins que la bagarre mais
quand tu vas travailler plus tard est-ce
que ça va te servir ben oui on peut
toujours être recrutés à ton âge
par exemple si on a fait une grosse
grosse bêtise et quand on va au but avec
ses bas on va vraiment apporter ça et ça
pourra nous servir
j'essaie de tout ce soit pour
d'argumenter avec ma mère pour avoir un
chien mais
[Musique]
est-ce que vous ressentez une différence
entre les deux écoles
bien sûr il ya une différence énorme et
non ça vous oui ça me choque ça me
choque parce que c'est grave c'est grave
l'état fait pas son travail et du coup
ben bouzid et génération donc c'est
clair que c'est triste
en plus ya des enseignants qui se
donnent à fond mais c'est un problème de
langue dire qu'on maîtrise même plus la
langue alors que c'est le premier moyen
pour évoluer dans la société il faut
être éduqué mais moi j'ai été dans des
étangs des mauvaises établissement je me
rends compte de la différence que j'ai
par rapport aux mêmes à nos jeunes qui
sont issus de des gros lycées parisiens
il ya une différence monstre
indifférence monstres ça c'est la vérité
donc soit on gomme égalité soit soit on
le met mais par contre on le sait
vraiment